hey there welcome to serious
jibber-jabber
I'm Conan O'Brien Mark Lewisohn is
widely recognized as the world's
foremost authority on the Beatles his uh
books which have chronicled in great
detail the band's activities on stage in
the studio and everywhere in between are
considered indispensable by Beatle fans
and music historians his latest project
is an extraordinary three-part biography
of the band the first volume of which is
entitled tune in and it is fantastic
Mark Lewisohn thank you so much for
being here pleasure thank you um alright
we should start with my belief when this
book came out that there's no way I
could read anything about the Beatles
that I did I mean I'm a huge Beatles fan
uh
and I've friends that I can talk with
for hours on end about the Beatles and
really get into the minutiae and I
thought I knew everything your book
comes along and I realized I knew
nothing and I was blown away by it it's
a real achievement thank you thank you
it's the first of three and I the reason
I'm writing is because I knew that in
biographical terms in history terms the
biggest story had never really been told
properly at least not what I consider
properly which is real with depth and
with authority and with painstaking
attention to detail and accuracy based
on real research and it's surprising
what you find because most of the books
that you have read on which you based
your knowledge in terms of our biography
they skim the surface you know the
writers will take a year or two and in
that time they'll maybe do six nine
months of research six nine months of
interviews and then they'll write and I
felt always this was a subject that
would merit much deeper research than
their and and it's showing because I
found so many people who have never been
in a book before who tell completely new
and different stories right and in
particular the documents the documents
tell a radically different story here's
the you know
the Beatles when I go to the bookstore
and you see there's certain sections JFK
assassination will be 800 books The
Beatles there'll be many books but and
so one can think I know this subject
I've we've seen it all and we've heard
it all and one of the problems that I
encountered and I saw it a little bit in
the Beatles Anthology is that there are
a lot of anecdotes you can tell that the
band has told a million times yes and I
started to realize at some point that
the Beatles the surviving Beatles may at
this point be the worst authority on on
what the Beatles were all about because
they have talked about it so much yeah
it's almost biology they've worn neural
grooves and they have stories that they
want to be true where ways they want to
see it I sometimes think Paul is too you
know we were just a band that made it
big and you know that it's a that was it
what it was we weren't really they're
just a bunch of lads and and you didn't
know they were Irish yeah they were
there that's my if you've heard my Irish
accent you'd be really horrified but
there is they almost became the worst
authorities on things Beatles because
they've talked about it so much and
their perspective is a little skewed I
know you had an interaction with George
Harrison once when he confronted you and
said how can you write about us isn't
that right yeah he said how can you
write about us because he weren't there
and I see his point completely because I
wasn't there but on the other hand how
many books will be written if it was if
only the direct observers or witnesses
to something we're actually writing it
so I take what he said on board I wasn't
there and at no point do I claim that I
was there but you can find people who
were there I mean they talk about the
pure essence of the Beatles is the four
of them together and very often it was
just the four of them maybe therefore a
Neil who's their assistant maybe a
driver but actually really in the back
of the car was four maybe five but
sometimes there were other people
there's a wonderful anecdote in the book
told by a guy called Bernie Boyle who
was a young kid in
in Liverpool that the Beatles kind of
allowed to go around with them you know
I'll carry a guitar in and getting for
nothing kind of thing because they were
playing dates every night of the week
playing geeks but they weren't really
geeks they were dances really and Bernie
was in the van when they went and did a
big gig in the South of England he was
with them all day long in the van and he
told me of the banter in the van and how
John was winding Paul up the hallway and
just that immediacy of that anecdote
means that other people were present and
you can get inside even the most private
of places because they were so accepting
of other people being around them
obviously because they've told their
story so many times certain elements of
it certain stories will be told too many
times I know some people who used to
look at Paul McCartney interviews and
say he's told story 103 89 and 602 B
because you could actually name which
ones he was gonna shoot Fox he said I'm
gonna push the button and then the yeah
this this story comes out but is it
their problem is it their fault that
they get asked the same questions all
the time I mean I interviewed Paul a lot
and I always asked him dare I say good
questions informed questions and he
responded perfectly yeah so I think
actually if they were ask better
questions we would have more from them
but they've been interviewed more times
than anybody I could possibly imagine
you know and part of my job for this
research is to find every interview
they've ever given in any medium at any
time to anyone and the material if you
if you look at it all in in total is
extraordinary they have said so much
they have been inquiry revealing in
their interviews what I I would say my
gonna say my favorite aspect of this
book is that it does not treat the
Beatles as an inevitability it does not
treat the Beatles as their this is the
story of the famous Beatles we all knew
no had to be you are approaching it like
a true historian and you are taking it a
day at a time
and what's clear
when you read the book and it's really
stunning and counterintuitive for a lot
of people is that the Beatles almost
didn't happen a million different ways
yes it almost went off the rails so many
times and I'm talking way before you
know the Beatle mania in 63 in in London
or the Sullivan in 64 in America there
are so many times when this maybe even
shouldn't have happened that that's what
makes the story so yes miraculous the
story is miraculous there are as you say
there are so many moments when it could
come unstuck and they - in order for it
to happen there are incredible amount of
occurrences of good fortune and you
would think well that's unlikely but the
the sheer number of them makes you
realize that actually this was kind of
meant to be I I don't necessarily
believe that there was a guiding hand on
this one but you look at it and you
think well hang on a minute this was
meant to be because they broke up once
nearly twice they they had severe but
when you turn broke up well yes you're
talking about what year waitwhat years
would they all break up there was a kind
of break up in 64 a few days 1960 60
there was there was a break up on paper
in 62 when the Beatles fired Pete best
and they got Ringo in in order to void
the contract they actually in legal
terms they claimed that they've broken
the the group up and reformed a minute
later there were just moments when you
think well if this hadn't have happened
it none of this would happen and it
always happened but they always had the
knack of attracting the right people to
them it's just something about them that
that made it work it's the sheer force
of their personalities I think they you
know I always think about the
songwriting yeah people have this
concept that John and Paul were writing
songs constantly from the time they're
about 16 until right up until their
first recording contract and that it's
just a fluid line that is not the case
there was a period of time right along
three-year period yeah that was a
surprise to me because I too thought
that that was the way they started
writing together the end of 50
seven beginning of 58 and they just
carried on but no they stopped after a
year or more because they actually they
done it it was either that we've written
some songs and we put them behind us and
and they didn't ever really play them
they were embarrassed of them and when
eventually well Brian Epstein became
their manager and that's why they
started to play them again because he
recognized that it gave them what today
we call a USP you know he gave them
something but they already had much that
nobody else had but this gave them
something else again not only are they
dynamic not only are they original not
only are they just incredibly
charismatic but also did you know two of
them write their own songs and it became
something that Brian sold them on if you
like so he he encouraged them to start
performing them and they were a bit
embarrassed in the early days in the
cavern it was like well you know they
really this audience knows us for our
well not just rock and roll but
principally rock and roll but they they
they tried it on the cavern audience
first because they felt they would be
more forgiving mm-hm
and then eventually of course within a
year or more that's all they can do
because then the shows have contracted
to half an hour and they've got to do
their hits the Malcom Gladwell couple of
years ago wrote this famous essay in one
of his books about 10,000 hours and
claimed avidly Dalls the outliers and it
the Beatles had their 10,000 hours and
that's what made them great but a lot of
people have their 10,000 hours and never
become anything close to the Beatles so
something else is at work there
something happens they are what's clear
when you read this book and I've had the
honor to talk to to talk to Ringo
mostly and some to Paul and what comes
across especially in talking to Ringo
not that long ago as he made it clear
there were a lot of bands in Liverpool
yeah
there were ton of bands in Liverpool
yeah they were not considered by many
people to be one of the premier bands in
Liverpool and then they go off to
Hamburg and something happens give you
any sense of what it was and I think it
was more than
10,000 hours something happened that
changed the equation yeah well first of
all though there were many groups in
Liverpool they were in a sense in the
second flush because the the true rock
and roll began in liver point 56 57 like
you did in most places and they were
really just school boys like George was
13 14 and the skiffle skiffle was the
music that they were blinded on again
exactly
so Ringo was in the biggest group Ringo
was always in the biggest group in
Liverpool he was in the biggest skiffle
group the Eddie Clayton group he was in
the biggest rock group before the
Beatles which was Rory storm but the
Beatles watched all this so they didn't
really have the experience to join in
they were just watching from the
sidelines the difference between them
and the others to begin with anyway was
the fact that most of the other guys
were Factory guys you know they would
leave school and go and work in the
factory the Beatles had this kind of art
school element to them that was crucial
to their development because John and
Stuart both went to art school Stuart
Sutcliffe that is and Paul and George
we're next door and they were very arty
as well not in the art school but they
were arty - so the Beatles thought
differently just calling themselves
Beatles was different to anybody else
because the others were all Rory storm
and the Hurricanes and Cass and the Cass
that's it that's a difference - is there
the Beatles and a lot of this again
people now because the Beatles changed
so much yeah people become inured or
dulled to what a revolution it was what
a revelation it was - they were
different because most bands were built
around the front usually the front guy
so it was unusual yeah for a band to
have really just be a unit of equals
yeah very unusual they had they had no
recognizable leader John actually was
the leader within the group
psychologically he was the leader he
started he was the oldest but he
exercised a democracy whereby everyone
got a say and there was no obvious
frontman and that was a strength that
they had so they go off to Hamburg in
Germany in August 1960 as pretty much
beginners still they haven't really had
a lot of stage experience
they've got a new drummer who they've
never played with and a bass guitarist
who's learning his instrument they're
all learning really because they haven't
had much time onstage but straightaway
when they go there and they're
confronted with the notion of having to
play six seven or eight hours a night
they come up with this incredible idea
unlike anybody else of let's not repeat
ourselves let's make sure that if anyone
happens to be in this bar at eight
o'clock in the evening and then comes
back a half past one that he won't hear
us do the same song as if anyone would
have noticed but it was a challenge for
themselves and so what we're looking at
here is guys who call themselves by a
different kind of name who have
different origins and who when they get
to Hamburg present themselves with
challenges and the combination of these
things plus of course the extraordinary
talent that they have they flower hugely
hugely so many groups went to Hamburg
and came back pretty much the same the
Beatles went to Hamburg and came back
completely refashioned yeah fans who had
known them in Liverpool before they went
and then saw them afterwards were blown
away you would be right but for the fact
that no one had really seen them in
Liverpool before they went they were
really so much on the fringes of what
was happening that no one had seen them
so when they came back and they were
billed as being the Beatles from Germany
the some of the kids who saw them and
actually saying speak good English and
so we only lived down the road right
people thought they were German they
thought they assumed they had to be
German the Beatles from Hamburg the and
they and they knocked everybody over
there completely because everyone else
is in nice little suits and they're
doing the big trend that year was a
group called the shadows a bit like the
American group the ventures and
everything kind of twangy guitar solos
posted through an echo box also they
remember the shadows would that that
thing that looks ridiculous now but yeah
people you know five guys playing their
instruments and doing little stance
steps yeah
in unison cars they choreographed which
the Beatles thought was absolute
[ __ ] were they just they were lucky
to have missed that trend while they
were away it all happen and they came
back and when what's everybody doing
yeah
and are we going to do that of course
we're not they always the thing about
the Beatles is and
it's true you tend to think of this
being true for Rubber Soul or revolver
or the White Album or Abbey Road that
they were original and always trying to
find some new sound but in fact that
evolution of always wanting to be
different from everybody else
never abiding by the common rules and
always feeling that we'll do it our way
no matter what people think would do a
howl way that begins well it begins when
the schoolboys but it equally begins
when they get back from Hamburg because
they they have a name like nobody else
they're playing music like nobody else
they look like nobody else and they are
extraordinarily magnetic on stage I've
got so many eyewitness accounts in this
book of their impact on the audience so
what happens in the world from 64-56 say
happens in microcosm in liverpool in 61
- and it's a magical story the yeah
there you've done an incredible amount
of work where you go to primary sources
like you decided that you needed to read
every issue of the Liverpool Echo and
you started what year 55 55
what checks first earlier stuff but 55
for a solid week and we're talking about
something that is not a veil
can't zip through it on your computer
you have to go to the library where did
you go to find every episode every issue
of the Liverpool Echo so the British
Library in London where they have
everything yeah but it's it's a slow old
job because it was a broadsheet
newspaper of 16 to 20 pages a day packed
with news I mean it's in these days it's
not a shadow like any no newspaper now
is a shadow of what it used to be but I
needed to immerse myself in Liverpool I
wasn't there in fact at that point I
wasn't even alive 55 so though it's a
world that I recognize because I grew up
in Britain in the 60s I needed to put
myself so that I could put the reader in
Liverpool and I think that's what makes
this works upsets this work apart I
think a lot of people can start with you
know every Beatle book I know
starts with the Blitz yeah and you to
the point where you just know the story
so well about they grew up there are war
babies and then you know John's the
brash one and Paul's the the cute quiet
one and George you know and you said
what yeah and yeah exactly or he I mean
he's a cute one and then George is the
quiet one and it to the point where it's
like it deadens you and I think the fact
that you went back and you're actually
looking at the primary sources like an
archaeologist yeah I have to get to what
is it like to live in Liverpool in 1958
in March I'm reading something that they
would have read yeah so you can get to
stuff that they will probably not even
room what some of the cinemas and the
theaters who's what what musicians are
visiting and where they're playing and
when so because sometimes they went to
shows the whole book is sequential and
there's no hindsight thinking in it so I
don't hint of the future because it's
not known that's not the feeling you get
when you read it is yeah it's going to
happen to these guys yeah it will judge
them which is actually it's fascinating
cuz it does suck you in you think I
wonder if these guys are going to pull
it together because as I said earlier
you know they they are not they're very
creative they're very talented they're
not always disciplined no they they
don't they're not people pleasers always
they are when it they really have to be
but there are a lot of times when
they're screwing up early on yeah
putting the band together and trying to
keep it afloat and that's what I keep
going back to is this sense that this
could easily not have happened these
guys could have messed it up and yeah
I'm very keen not to write a book about
legends you know the two words that
drive me mad these days more than any
other legends and I call ya iconic
everybody's iconic I won't let people
use those terms with me yeah because I
find I don't know why you're laughing uh
the one of the things that you talk
about these miracles say so one of them
that's absolutely miraculous I mean
Lenin meets McCartney and we all know
that that's that's fairly miraculous
yeah George just the right chemistry
John has a personality trait where he
can be brash he can be of a bit of a
bully but he lets he tolerates younger
kids if they show deference and if they
have something to offer so people forget
George was much younger than John in you
know a few years is a massive gap back
then so George is this kid who doesn't
seem very impressive at all but John
lets him into the fold it's it's almost
seems crucial that John has this trait
where he wants to dominate but at the
same time he lets people in who other
kids may not have let in yes that makes
sense yeah there's a the guy who
introduced John to Paul Ivan Vaughan was
a childhood for you went to school with
Paul but he was a childhood friend of
John John had a gang he always had a
gang around him and he was always the
leader just by natural order and instead
of it being John Paul George Ringo was
John Pete Nige and Ivan and Ivan Ivan's
remar because unfortunately is not with
us anymore but one of the remarks he
made about John was that he was in
extraordinarily accepting of him though
he was younger and and and didn't have
as much about him as John did John was
accepting yes you can come and play and
bring your cars and we'll play cars
whatever they were like fighting seven
years old so it was - when he was a
teenager he was seventeen and a half
when he met George for the first time
and John was quite an old seventeen and
a half you know he had he had burns he
was a Teddy Boy which was you know the
British style that was kind of something
like Elvis but seemingly from external
appearances at least aggressive you
would cross the road to avoid people
like that and George is just turning 15
he's in fact he's not yet 15 and he's a
small boy still he's not yet adolescent
so there is a world of difference
between them and not many seventeen and
a half year olds are interested in
having a 15 year old kid taken around
now John did do an interview in 1970
with Rolling Stone in which he talked
about how remembered George being this
kid who was always hanging around all
the bloody time and you know always he
here again I think he's speaking of one
or two particular instance
when he was going out with his
girlfriend Cynthia and Georgia was
bunking off school and he would tag
along to the pictures with him in the
afternoon but generally speaking George
was there because John allowed him to be
there that is a very special trait to
have and it meant that he was open to
whatever George could bring and you
mentioned deference earlier I'm not sure
that John particularly wanted people to
defer to him they had he had to have the
last word that's unusual but what he
most valued was people who stood up to
him mm-hmm
because if you were a pushover he'd push
you over right but if you stood up to
him fine you can stay and George did
stand up to him because George though
only not yet 15 always had a kind of a
wisdom and a quiet strength about him
that John that John obviously recognized
the would talk about miraculous events
fryin Epstein shows up and now looking
back he is a gift from the heavens for
these guys because he sees their talent
he's the only one who sees them in 62
and says they're going to be the biggest
thing ever I found them I am NOT a
manager but I'm going to be one I'm that
they are it they are going to be it he
saw the whole thing
and he also had taste and you think
about how many people how many bands get
the wrong manager early on almost
everyone yes he had taste and he cared
about them and he put them ahead of you
know what business concerns I would say
that in fact there are quotes from Bryan
in which he says this that he devoted
himself to them yeah and he was a man of
tremendous energy when he was fired by a
new passion he would pour everything
into it he would just consume himself
with whatever it was that was
interesting him and the Beatles were
miraculous to him they came along at
just the right time in his life matters
he came along at just the right
time in their lives it was the perfect
marriage if you like of manager and
artists
he not only cared he was honest how many
Rock managers have been honest you know
in through the history of rock and roll
yeah they but again it's another example
of them finding the right person at the
right time which was a happy that they
happen to them so often that you can't
help but think well yeah of course yeah
it was going to happen wasn't it but in
fact one of the questions I mean people
often ask me what if so-and-so what if
so-and-so hadn't happened I'm not very
good on what-if questions because it
didn't happen so what's there to talk
about yeah also I don't know who does
with probably one exception and that is
what if Brian Epstein hadn't come along
would the Beatles still have made it
people asked what I found with this book
is that had he not come along they would
have broken up because they went to
Hamburg the second time in the spring of
1961 they came back at the end of June
or the beginning of July and they
started playing again on Merseyside they
were commanding about five times the
nightly fee of any other group they were
packing them in so promoters paid this
high fee through gritted teeth but look
at the business they brought in for
everybody there was a newspaper called
mercy beat by this point and they wrote
about the Beatles more than any other
and when the opinion poll the popularity
poll ran the Beatles want it they were
far and away the biggest group in
Liverpool so this is typical of them
they got bored there were no challenges
for them from July into August into
September they're beginning to go well
we're next because it was called a
circuit you would play the circuit
so-and-so hall on a Monday night
so-and-so Hall on the Tuesday night and
literally it was a circuit they were
just going round and round and round and
round and round and that might be enough
for most but for Lennon and McCartney
and Harrison and Pete best was there as
well it was just like what next what
next you know where's the challenge
and Bob Willa who was some bear
confidants at that time he was the guy
who was they saw him virtually every
night at the different halls he was the
DJ and the emcee and one of them kind of
like the Alan Freed of Liverpool but not
as wild he he is category Gore was
categoric that they were going to break
up unless something happened for them
some breakthrough happened they were
going to break up and John and Paul go
off to Paris in October 61 and they
leave George and Pete behind and they
break the bookings with a few promoters
which burns even more bridges one by one
they were pissing off every promoter
that they were who was paying them so
they John and Paul face the prospect of
returning to Liverpool and virtually no
bookings anymore because they've annoyed
everybody one time too many
yeah and Brian comes along yeah and
Brian comes along and he makes a promise
to them to double their income which is
really hard considering that he can't
book them into any of the places they've
been playing because the promoters don't
want them anymore but they're going to
he's going to double their income and
he's going to get them onto the radio
and hopefully television and he will do
all he can to get them a record contract
that's the that's the Holy Grail that is
the Holy Grail make a record yeah I've
seen I know you've seen these but I've
seen Brian Epstein would make these
sheets you know these booking sheets
that you're okay lads you're gonna go
and play and I've seen them actually
typed out and I think Ringo Ringo's
mother kept everything and he put out a
book not too long ago and he has you can
actually look at them yes and what's
really interesting about them I don't
know the names of you know rural towns
around London but you'll know which
places I'm talking about but there'll be
a sheet that you're supposed to go to
Oxfordshire and play a gig at this hall
and it will say in it it's typed out
supposedly pretty good audience you know
but they are they're very Protestants so
some of your shenanigans won't go over
too well so maybe you want to pull it
back there
details about what he's done his
research and he's found out I mean this
is when they're you know these these
gigs may not even be that consequential
but he's telling them this is how you
this is the advanced stuff you need to
know about playing yes that small hall
and it's important that you remember
these things
yeah Brian's attention to detail was
extraordinary and he presented them with
two pieces of paper every week one was
the coming weeks engagements as you've
described it Monday here Jesse they're
two half-hour slots one 45 minute slot
give him a good show it's the first
first show for such-and-such a promoter
do your best to impress him because
we'll get more and so on and the the
second sheet was the last week's
accounts down to the penny yeah and they
would actually go to the office on a
Friday and pick up their money which in
a little wage packet with the the top
sealed over and the slip inside the
explaining how much it was but it was
cashed people they didn't have bank
accounts yeah and we're talking here of
a completely different age if you like
no bank accounts as well as no mobile
phones so Brian was incredible for them
because it gave them a level of
organization that they'd never had they
were always a bit a bit haphazard on
their own whenever they had to organize
themselves they would usually turn up
late ragged in some way and their
amplifiers were was shockingly poor and
piece by piece he actually got them up
to scratch the main one of course is he
got them to tidy up their appearance
mm-hmm which meant that the myth was
they didn't like being put you know they
had these leather suits and they didn't
like these new these new outfits but
that's been disproven yeah mankind being
what it is
authors do like to have someone to pick
on or the public do as well and I always
filled with this story you can't really
pick on John Paul George or ringo so you
pick on some of the people around them
and give them a bit of a kickin mm-hmm
and brian has been he suffered a bit of
a kicking from many authors who
who wished to portray a particular
element of his life when out without
necessarily looking at it in balance and
I'm only interested in the truth I'm not
interested in agendas or more bias of
any kind whatsoever so I look at what
Brian did for them in totality and the
business with the suits actually turns
out on close inspection to be a
completely different way to the way it's
been projected which is that he said to
them if you stay dressed as you are all
in leather leather trousers leather
usually wore black t-shirts leather
jackets leather trousers and something
like cowboy boots or just human heel
boots of some kind that's fine but I
can't book you in two places outside
Liverpool because they don't know you
they don't know of your reputation on
image alone they would say well we're
not having them because they look like
trouble they look like you know they
dressed on stage as the kind of person
you wouldn't want to have in the hall
from an audience point of view I mean
even in the cavern it was meant to be no
jeans and they're on stage playing in
jeans so there was you know the
management always had to wrestle with
something when the Beatles were around
so he said you know if you carry on
dressed like that
I your optic opportunities will be more
limited than you would wish them to be
so you've got a choice you can either
change you can either stay as you are
and and stay pretty much playing the
same places or you can change your
appearance into something else something
more presentable in the in the mode of
the day and that'll be problem solved so
with that information they decided that
they would get suits and in fact I found
the tailor a guy could Walter Smith who
is 80 something now who was a young 20
30-something then who fitted them up for
their suits and he told me how
particular they were about the
particular narrowness of the lapels and
the the narrowness of the trousers the
child is kept going back for alteration
the the narrow ties are they had they
were basically going for a kind of
Italian mud look now no other group in
Liverpool who wore suit or anything like
those suits they were still different
they still maintained they're in
individuality they just got out of the
leather but it was their decision mmm
and this was what Brian did time and
again now one of the reasons why it's
laughably untrue that he could have
forced them into suit is because there
is no way that he could have forced
Lennon McCartney Harrison and ultimately
Starr to do anything if they didn't want
to do it because we're talking here
about some of the world's most
opinionated young men they always had an
opinion they were never shy to air it it
goes on to this day and if they were
being told to do something that they
didn't want to do they would usually
tell you where to get off I Brian
learned the hard way that you very
quickly in fact that you know if he
tried saying boys do this F Brian in
that uh watch the language uh I'm
kidding it really doesn't matter um in
the in that vein Paul pretty quickly
butts heads with Brian Epstein which is
interesting because you always think of
him uh it's that's the moment in Yellow
Submarine you know
he's that where he's thrown the bouquet
and he's the diplomat he's the darling
he's going to make he's going to make
you know that Lennon's the troublemaker
and that Paul is the you know
lubricating the situation making it all
move but Paul had a side to him that was
difficult and he was a real problem for
Brian Epstein at some point they won't
have their difficult sides but Paul was
the one that Brian had the most trouble
with for sure because Paul was the most
conspicuously ambitious for the Beatles
John and George were both ambitious too
no doubt about it but but they would be
more laid back he wouldn't quite see it
he wouldn't say quite so openly as you
would with Paul and again I wasn't there
but I spoke to so many people who were
and you get to see the personality
through all the years anyway Paul has
never liked anyone telling him what to
do there are quotes from him in this
book the go right back to his earlier
school days at the age of five where he
didn't like the teachers because they
told him what to do he had a job in a
factory for a couple of
which is a nice little tail that's in
the book didn't like the boss because it
kept telling him what to do so Brian
comes along and says boys you you should
be here on Friday you should be there on
Saturday we should should I'll be there
if I want to be there but don't tell me
I should so he and Brian did kind of
lock horns and it was a relationship
that never really was very brilliant
even in Brian's 1964 water biography a
cellar full of noise which is fairly
anodyne in the way that it approached
most of the subjects he openly reveals
that Paul is his biggest problem he said
I've read that book and was remembered
at the time being struck that it's this
very cheerful oh the boys and the lads
and it's this supposed to feel like it
could be a puff piece and then there is
a part where he's very revealing about
yeah Paul being a bit of a prima donna
there's actually a time that stands out
it's in your book where Paul refuses to
show up for a gig and it costs them the
gig and they go to his house and he says
I'm not going yeah well in fact it
manifested itself in the very first
meeting the first constructive business
meeting they had with Brian Epstein
beginning of December 1961 his visa he
he's only known them a few days he's
already been down to London to see if he
can get them a recording contract in
fact they all do they kind of have one
already and they've signed the contract
and it's all in German and they've got
no idea what they've signed they signed
anything until Brian came along so they
have this meeting at which they're going
to discuss how things evolve from here
and Paul doesn't show up and they wait
for him and wait for him and eventually
George goes and phones him and turns out
that um Paul is in the bath he's just
got up and he's in the bath and and
Brian is livid because you know he the
risk at this point is all Brian's you
know there was no risk for the Beatles
in taking Brian as their manager there
was considerable risk for Brian because
the Beatles reputation was was quite
poor at that point amongst the people
who you know were meant to employ them
and you know he faced the prospect of
being embarrassed of losing money
and having them walk out on him and all
those things there was no contract yet
so where was Paul and Paul's I'll get
there when I'm ready is essentially what
he was doing and then a couple of months
later there's this three dates that
brian has arranged for them with the
Liverpool University different kind of
audience again as I said because he
couldn't book them where they had been
playing he was having to be imaginative
in how they would find work and Paul
just I'm not coming to say I'm not
coming you know he always felt that he
was the one who was always trying to
make things happen and he kind of went
tonight huh but I can't be bothered and
it was a great embarrassment to Brian
and annoying for the others but we're
talking about young guys here we're not
talking about mature men we're talking
here about kids adolescence and and this
is what happens I mean groups
notoriously fight bands they're called
now but in these days they call groups
you hear incredible stories of bands on
the road fighting I mean really really
fighting get guys who hate each other
they go on stage and play with that
absolutely hate each other the Beatles
were not like that the Beatles were
great friends of one another genuinely
close friends strong friends and this is
another reason why they were able to
make it and make it so big and stay sane
through what in volumes two and three
years which are just beyond but beyond
belief in the sense that they'd never
happen to anybody else ever so that what
they're experiencing they experienced
with the first time and they cope with
it incredibly well and that's because
they are so tight they're so they say
always felt they had an advantage over
Elvis that Elvis was yes you know Elvis
was the one guy and then he had you know
he has Memphis mafia but they're not
going to tell him no but there are there
lip-service yeah and the Beatles always
recognized they were fortunate that they
had each other any one of them started
to yeah get a little inflated ego they
would they would feel you know they kept
each other and she kept each other and
Shagga and they go through the sixties
with a very
coterie of people around them it's
really small you know it really is
shocking when you look at you think
about its Neil Aspinall and mal Evans
mal Evans when you think about a band of
that caliber the biggest band biggest
show business act possibly in the
history of the world yeah and they've
got one guy schlepping there yeah
guitars drums around and setting them up
and it's unheard of
yeah it's insane that it didn't multiply
to 1520 pedia they never had a heavy
they never had an employee of theirs hit
anybody
I mean Neil could take care of himself
but he wasn't violent he would make sure
that they were unns they were unscathed
and that was it that was his job you
know in in you know he would just say
get out of the way but he wouldn't
actually knock anybody out and mal was a
big guy but he wouldn't hit anybody
either
so they when they came to America in 64
65 66 with it with extremely small
retinue like five people yeah you know
Brian mal Neil who else was there and
then relying on in local police driving
yeah or something yeah yeah which of
course was was problematic because in
the states particularly in 64 65 and not
less in 66 I would say the police always
felt that the local police wherever they
arrived they would handle it and of
course they would always be caught out I
mean compare the sheer scope of the the
mania that was going on around them and
they'd go into some really dangerous
situations but they always got through
and they always got through those guys
didn't suck up to them either you know
they were they spoke straight to them
The Beatles were straight talkers who
appreciate people talking straight to
them the you know half the crux adult
probably the whole story of the Beatles
is the songwriting yeah which we touched
on it before but you have these guys no
one had done this before they write
their writing their own songs yeah and
I've always thought the prelude to
talking about that is their selection of
covers that they did as a
and we're very unlike what other people
were doing at the time yeah before they
were performing their own songs for
people they were playing covers like
everyone played covers but they were
playing different kinds of music they
intentionally wanted to play music that
other people weren't playing yes they
played music by girl groups they loved
the girl groups of this American girl
groups of the 60s yes and they thought
those are terrific songs so I used to
remember it dawning on me that you know
boys you know Ringo singing it's a great
song we listened to it and it for a
while remembered long before I knew when
I first heard it I thought that's an odd
song yeah why is Ringo singing about
boys you know it's got a homoerotic
quality to it which I rather enjoy now
but uh but it but I found later on that
they just loved that song and they
decided we could change it to girls but
we're not going to do that which who
cares just yet play it that way that
they were consistently trying to find
different kinds of material that
probably expanded them greatly as
musicians
yeah well Liverpool as we said earlier
had a rock and roll scene before the
Beatles came along in an embryonic form
if you like it was the Beatles return
from Hamburg and their extraordinary
popularity immediately that opened up
the scene for everyone and suddenly in
the wake of the Beatles they are the top
now and in the wake of the because loads
of other groups form loads of different
venues open and there is suddenly a lot
of competition mm-hmm
they're the headlining act but the
headlining act didn't necessarily play
the last on the bill which would you get
these days because in those days most
very few kids had a car so the prime
spot will be the one kind of nine
o'clock in the evening because after
that the last buses go in fact if you
watch some of the Beatles concert films
from like Shea Stadium for example Paul
does this thing of you know it's going
to be this one's gonna have to be our
last song and it taps his watch as if
it's like you know you've got to go and
catch the last bus and he does this
thing with this with his hand you know
as if you know it's time to go to go
home and go to bed now yeah that's
because they played mid-evening in
Liverpool rather than the end but the
point is there were so many other groups
on the bill sometimes as many as 10 acts
on one bill great Rock promotions in
Liverpool
there wasn't anything like this
happening anywhere else in the world
they would be in the dressing room and
they'd hear the other groups who were on
before them doing their songs so you
know Gerry and the Pacemakers just on
long tall Sally what should we do we'll
cross it out then or whatever so they
realized that it would be to their
advantage if they developed a repertoire
that was unlike anybody else's and so
they started digging around the b-sides
of records they were a professional
group The Beatles that is they didn't
have when they came back from Hamburg
the second time particularly they didn't
have to go and look for any other jobs
they could earn a living and a very good
living and that more than their parents
were earning just by playing rock and
roll at night that liberated their
daytime sort of working in the factory
or wherever they could be in the record
shops and they spent a lot of time in
the record shop squeezed into the little
listening booths called browser is
asking the assistants usually the the
girls to put on anything American the
myth that they got everything from the
sailors who sailed the Atlantic between
New York and Liverpool is is just that
it's a myth it's they got their
repertoire from records because most of
the American record labels had a
licensing deal with the UK label and
they would be issued in Britain so in
the shop they'd be listening to anything
American and they'd listen to the b-side
as well as the a side and they found so
much music that nobody else had the
opportunity to hear and so they they did
these songs that nobody else knew and
they also arranged them because often
rock and roll songs would have a piano
or a saxophone or horn section they just
had three guitars and drums so they
would do an instant rearrangement and
they played like that night that night
and probably it was a little bit rough
because they hadn't played it before but
they were playing so often they were
playing typically at 61 they play 350
dates in one year in 365 days
62 was only a few less so they're
rehearsing on stage if you like and and
they are dynamic and what they love is
rhythm and blues they love American
rhythm and blues and rhythm and blues
then we had two definitions it could
mean the kind of Willie Dixon Howlin
wolf rhythm and blues like the stones
got into or it could mean the other
rhythm and blues the Billboard R&B chart
which is what became Sol which is you
know the Shirelles the Isley Brothers
and so on that Smokey Robinson Smokey
Robinson and the miracles that other POC
that was their passion
so it's I've always had this theory that
people say how do people how to
songwriters like that come along yeah
and you think okay well they obviously
had this incredible genius aptitude but
which certainly helps is that they had
big years they they listened to
everything and they sucked it in and
when you say that they had to arraign
rearrange the songs themselves and you
also remember that today if I want to I
play some guitar if I want to learn a
song it's instantaneous yeah I can go
and hit an app and type in the song that
I want to learn and it will tell me
exactly what the chords are when they
come in if I want to play the lead I can
find out how to play the lead I can find
out what chord with key it's in I can
watch video of 55,000 people doing it
with close-ups of the hands they had
none of that so they had to absorb the
essence of songwriting by listening and
playing all these great cover tunes that
they loved which I think must sink in at
some point yeah where their education
was playing so many different kinds of
music yeah George Harrison had this
great quote of you know in nineteen the
late 50s you could barely get a cup of
sugar let alone a rock and roll record
yeah and because it was so scarce
because the the thing that they most
sought after was so scarce they went
looking for it deep you know Paul tells
fantastic anecdote of how he and George
got on a bus to go to the other side of
Liverpool for someone
who would show them accord the B 7 B 7
chord here and that that hunger that
desire is um is a very good driver if
you've got everything so easy and laid
out for you yes they had if they had
apps where they could get everything
they'd become bored and as he said the
the thing the lethal thing for the Beals
was boredom yes
also they wouldn't have anything that
nobody else didn't have even you know
what was going to make them unique the
effort of going and finding something
was making them unique they had big ears
as you say and they did absorb
everything and that's what creative the
best creative talent will do suck it all
in add your own original mix to it and
then put it back out again in a
different form and at the time that they
get their record contract the Beatles
major influences the music of Gerry
Goffin and Carole King the scenes of
Goffin and King all those wonderful
songs by the Shirelles and little ever
and so on the crickets and so when they
began recording Lennon and McCartney
were writing in that vogue the songs on
their first LP Please Please Me are all
their own songs I kind of like Goffin
and King songs where the somehow or
other there's this wonderful mix of an
upbeat melody with a downbeat lyric it
was a wonderful nap that Goffin and King
managed and particularly appealed to
John and Paul so without any of these
influences from America you wouldn't
have had the Beatles there's a great
story in the book of a guy called Tony
karriker who went to art school with
John now passed away but I got a
fantastic interview with him spent a day
with him and he was an ardent record
collector and he discovered in the late
1950s that you could send away to the
American Embassy in London in Grosvenor
Square in London and they would send you
Library of Congress recordings made by
Alan Lomax down in the field somewhere
in Tennessee or wherever all those great
original early blues of Sleepy John STS
and all these fantastic American blues
artists that no one really had ever
heard of and the American Embassy
he would send post free well return
postage paid in fact records on loan
anyone to anyone who asked and so John
got access to all these American blues
records courtesy of the American
government which i think is pretty cool
and he didn't necessarily inform his
musical style but he knew it from that
point on he knew it and he could speak
about it with some authority because of
the American government I think you
there's this moment and I'll back up a
second I had the great opportunity to
hang out with you a little bit in London
and you gave me a fantastic tour of
Abbey Road studio which you know was a
dream come true for me cuz I had read
everything you had written about the
Abbey Road and the studio sessions and I
had had a idea in my head of what it was
going to be like but then to actually
see the place it was the it was the most
I've ever known about a place and not
having not have seen it and then I saw
it and you showed me around you're very
generous with your time and then
afterwards we were walking along and we
were going to go get a cup of coffee and
you pointed out to me you said that
right there is the place where which is
a few blocks from heavy Road that's
where Brian sent the telegram to the
boys tell them just secured a recording
contract I think he said need new need
new songs yes which they misinterpreted
is that right yeah what did try to
remember what the telegram said now
please rehearse new material I think it
said new material right yeah and and in
Hamburg perhaps it just fed the way they
were thinking anyway John and Paul took
that as a sign to actually resume some
writing rather they had actually both
recently written in spring 62 a song
each Paul did one called pinwheel twist
which we've never heard which was a
twist record opens and and John did ask
me why which eventually came out but
they took it as a sign to you know come
up with something new and they didn't
want to when they recorded they didn't
want to do anybody else's songs they the
shift was here we will do our own see
that's that's a
doesn't sound like a leap to anybody
today that sounds natural at the time
that was here are these guys they
shouldn't have made it this far as we've
said 10,000 ways it could have gone
wrong she should have gone wrong and now
they're getting a recording contract and
nobody has a recording contract yeah and
this is where if you're smart you play
it safe and you do some of the covers
it's going to sound great we know how to
do this and they say it's our own songs
or nothing yeah that's absolutely
stunning yeah it is it is and it's
absolute indicative of who they have
always been by this point and who they
will always be through all the years to
come what they don't know is that
they're being given a song to record a
song called how do you do it which they
don't like but actually rearranged to
record it and at the end of recording it
when it looks like the thing that they
least want to happen is bound to happen
they are going to have to come out with
a song that isn't theirs John goes and
talks to George Martin whenever there
was a heavy moment in the Beatles though
there was a democracy there the others
would all the other three would always
just keep quiet and look at John and
John would have to go and say whatever
needed to be said and at that point it
was clear that he was the leader and he
went up and said to George Martin we
really really really don't want you to
release that song that we've just
recorded please please use our own song
and George said no actually no but in
the course of the seven days art that
followed other pressures came to bear
that the Beatles knew nothing about and
George Martin did drop how do you do it
and the Beatles always assumed that it
was George who had listened to their
requests and and thought as a result of
that what a fantastic guy he was which
of course he was they liked him anyway
but this was this was it you know George
Gray told George ease listen to what pal
requesting her but it wasn't quite like
that but it looked that way and so their
first record was their record
love me do and their second mom was
there record please please me and then
it never stopped there was no question
then of them covering anybody else's
though they covered four albums they
didn't cover four singles they always
wrote their own and John and Paul had a
particular view of what made a single
and what made an album tray and that
being something about energy and speed
they never quite defined what it was
themselves but it's clear when you look
at what their choices were that that's
they knew that song like I wanna hold
your hand is a single yeah for example
this boy is a b-side but but what a
b-side yeah they had some b-sides oh
yeah what's you also discovered in your
research you debunk another myth and
this was really stunning because most
people the story that I've always heard
is that nobody wants the Beatles no
record company wants the Beatles and
they can't get a recording contract
George Martin sees something he's
produced The Goon The Goon Show he's
he's not sure about them his musicians
but he thinks they've got something and
he takes a chance that's not quite true
is that right no no it's not
you said debunk myths i I didn't set out
to debunk any yes yeah but I don't even
set out it's a myth for me that's right
they what happens is that they just kind
of fall away because when you actually
tell the real story you think we're hang
on wasn't it well obviously this is what
happened the reality is that I I too
like everybody else when I wrote the
recording sessions book I assumed that
the Beatles first visit to Abbey Road
was an audition of some kind of test an
artist test or a commercial test that
would have been the phrase of the time
until in 1991 I was rooting around in
the archives at EMI I love paperwork
paperwork ease is what I searched the
world for and I found all sorts of
pieces of paper which pointed very
clearly to the fact that when the
Beatles first came to Abbey Road they
were actually already under contract
that there was not a test at all they
were already signed
so is all why would they be signed when
George Martin hasn't even met them yet
so I was working with George on a TV
special the making of Sergeant Pepper
and I spread out all the I photocopied
everything and I spread them all out in
front of George on the kind of edit
suite desk and I said I don't understand
what's happening here can you please
explain to me the documents had his
signature on them from 62 and he looked
at them and and and I could hide he had
no answer he couldn't actually explain
what it was he was baffled by it and I
could see he was genuinely baffled
he kind of them talked himself into
believing that the other story yes of
how they were signed and therefore when
confronted with this genuinely no longer
remembered it that way that was okay for
the time it liberal left me unsatisfied
but I knew that you know there was
something there that was unsolved well
when I came to write these books I knew
I had to get to the bottom of that one
I couldn't just have a conundrum in the
book of such magnitude so it all fell
into place when I lucked into well I've
been looking for him for years but in
the end I lucked into finding a guy
called Kim Bennett Kim mail Kim who was
he worked at an EMI Music Publishing
firm called Ardmore beechwood and he had
liked to Lennon and McCartney song that
he had heard on the Decca tape the
failed audition for Decca um and wanted
to publish it and through his interest
the Beatles Brian Epstein found himself
with George Martin in May 1962
discussing a contract now why was George
Martin offering them a contract well
it's a convoluted and and quite
multifaceted combination of reasons but
the reality is that he was given them as
a chore he had his arm twist was in the
side so it was an assignment they was in
effect they were signed by EMI and then
it was like well who shall we give them
to EMI had four in
house producers at that time and for
various reasons
George was given that job so they were
signed he had never met them the only
bit of their music he had heard he
didn't like didn't rate at all highly so
why on earth would he assign them when
he met them and this is what so
tremendous about George Martin being the
right guy when he met them he recognized
immediately that these guys were
original that they had attitude that
they had opinions that they spoke up
that they were funny that they were
charismatic and that they were the
something who else was called something
he was himself a maverick in everything
he did he didn't like abiding by the
rules he was always trying to subvert
the rules in the best way possible in
the creative sense and when he met them
he recognized that they were the same so
he knew that they were good guys and
that something might come of this but
what would they record and it was at
that point that he decided he would find
them a song which was the role of a
producer he wasn't even called a
producer then he was an A&R man and A&R
people at record companies wore tent
these days was scout the talent but they
won't necessarily take them into the
studio but his job was to find the
artists and artists and repertoire so he
found the artist then he went looking
for the repertoire which was how do you
do it and then he said come down boys
you're going to make a record the great
strength of the relationship between the
Beatles and George Martin manifests
itself very fast by November of 62 still
within the realm of this book he is
completely tuned into who they are he
realizes how original they are he wants
to do an album with them he talks about
going to the cavern and making their
first album a live album which is what
Please Please Me would have been and
he's he's fully tuned in and when they
make the police Please Me single he
presses the button to say
congratulations boys you've just made
your first number one and he meant it he
wasn't bull he wasn't speaking Pulgas
George didn't do that he was straight we
talked about how lucky the Beatles were
to have Bryan
George Martin was the only producer in
London who could possibly have coped
with their attitude mm-hmm
the only producer Hill in London who
would have allowed them to start
breaking the rules as quickly as they
did because with in 1963 they get very
comfortable in the studio and start
trying things and most producers would
have said well you do it my way
boys or not at all but he was receptive
to their ideas probably knew it was
unwise to stop them because they were so
strong in their opinions but but he was
receptive he also didn't insert his name
as the co composer on the b-side or the
a site even like some of his colleagues
did and which was a fairly well known
trick in the business in order to earn a
little bit of money on the side he was
straight so they had the best manager
and they had the best producer and and
this has just kind of happened to them
like the because you've let my George
Martin to this day Ringo has a grudge
yeah against the recently departed
George Martin to this day can't let it
go that he was asked to sit on the
sidelines yeah well Andy white is he
white the session drummer sits in yeah
and ringo's never forgotten it and is
mad about it and it just made me think
Ringo has always been the you know
people will agree it's Lennon McCartney
and then of course Harrison's brilliant
and then I'm a big defender of Ringo's
because it's easy for people if they're
looking for yeah
who do we make a joke about yeah I
talked to many drummers the drummer in
my band who's a brilliant drummer Ringo
is one of his favorites it's just but
he's always he has an interesting spot
and and sometimes he's underappreciated
but it feels does feel to me like he was
crucial to the whole thing coming
together in the end yeah he was yeah he
was I like the fact that we know that he
still has a problem with George Martin
having replaced him 54 years ago yeah we
know that because he said it and what
that says
is that he's a grudge keeper yeah yeah
he got over it I mean he and George went
on to have a fantastic relationship
mutually respectful and Ringo never ever
let him down as a drummer after that
first session but the fact that Ringo
kept the grudge tells us something about
ringers personality that we need to know
and because they always remember who did
them down not many have big but in the
very early days when they were told you
will never make it from Liverpool just
don't well we will you know and there's
a great anecdote a few pages in the book
where I described the first trip to
London to promote a record and
everybody's telling them you'll never
make it from Liverpool and you'll never
make it with the name Beatles what a
stupid name change it and they just
thought yes we will and we'll show you
you mentioned defending Ringo I think we
don't need to defend Ringo anymore
because it's time for the attacks on
Ringo to stop hmm you know again I said
earlier that people like to have a
victim figure that they can they can
beat Brian Epstein being a notable one
Magic Alex the Maharishi would like to
make fun of all these people without
actually looking at their role in things
properly Ringo has been something of a
laughingstock since 63 as soon as they
broke through because he sat at the back
because it was a bit smaller than then
because he had a bigger nose because he
didn't sing so many songs because he
appeared to be the spare part but within
that group there were four of them and
they all recognized the absolute
fundamental necessity of having each
other there Ringo is he was they picked
him he's the chosen one if you like he's
the guy they went we want you they went
to a lot of trouble to get Ringo they
did at a very difficult time yeah when
it would have been easier to just stick
with Pete best
oh you they were never going to do that
yeah never I mean the thing about Pete
was he lasted much longer than then they
wanted him to because of their own
lethargy really and their own as John
called it cowardice because they didn't
want to face sacking him because they
thought he might hit them but Ringo was
the guy they actually went out
got they did have one or two other
drummers temporarily but all had people
in there are people who can claim that
they want he want they really wanted me
but now they really did want Ringo and
and the beauty of that is what Neil
Aspinall explained to me is the chain
which is the name order John Paul George
Ringo John started it he brings in Paul
Paul brings in George George brings in
Ringo they all wanted Ringo but George
was the one who really made the move to
bring him to make sure that they landed
him so that meant the Ringo's
relationship with George was always that
bit closer because he knew that he was
there because of George hmm but the
reason why they wanted him is because he
was they loved playing with him I mean
when you're in a band and you're on the
front line and the drummer is not the
right guy for whatever reason you know
it and similarly when the chemistry is
right you know and every time they play
with Ringo before he joined it felt
great yeah they play with him numerous
times yes they would always switch off
and if their drummer was they didn't
have a drummer they were in and they
were playing the same venue as Rory
storm yeah and there's great pictures
Ringo has of him hanging out with John
and Paul and George when he's not even
in the Beatles yes they they're they're
hanging out after a show they really
knew him from 1960 in Hamburg because
his group Rory storm and hurricanes and
the Beatles shared 12 hours then seven
nights six nights a week in a Kaiser
Color Club at the bar in Hamburg so why
did they want Ringo they wanted him
because first of all his what character
and personality it was a fit secondly
temper rock-solid temper unwavering beat
metronomic perfect for guitarists and
singers the guy before Pete they always
felt that he wavered on his beat you
know he was erratic he speeded up he
slowed down you know the jokes about
drummers um Ringo wasn't you know rock
solid
he's also rock solid through every
outtake yeah he sees y'ever there's
never it's never Ringo it's the problem
and all styles I mean if they play honey
it's a kind of nineteen twenties down
span shuffle there's ringo if they're
playing hell helter-skelter it's heavy
rock
there's ringo if they're playing or
whatever it was you know you name it
yeah all the incredible variety of
styles of the beatles music I mean the
Beatles music catalogue is breathtaking
in its breadth and depth of musical
innovation and style one drummer
yeah all the way through except for a
couple of tracks on the way album when
he walked out for a while I love the
fact that Ringo was the first people to
quit yeah by the way because it just
shows the main strength of mind yeah and
that was the strength of mine that they
all needed you know that the Pete I'm
not trying to be anti Pete here but for
the Beatles the contrast with Pete was
dramatic yeah because Pete was quiet
very very quiet wouldn't say anything
and when they when when they finished
playing and they'd go out to a bar Pete
will go home it was only over the three
of them with Ringo they became a
foursome for the first time it's the
four headed monster yeah that's what
yeah when the Beatles would go and check
out the stones yeah stones would see
these four guys and leather coats come
in and say it's the four headed master
they did everything together I love the
fact that the Beatles enjoyed each
other's company so much that whenever
any one of them got an enthusiasm for
something which they always did because
they were enthusiastic guys and very
receptive is there anything around them
a fashion for example or a gimmick a toy
or all of them will get or a mustache
yeah be ready I'll get them yeah they
did these things in unison and it wasn't
as something as as ordained as you know
next week we will all do this they just
turned each other on with their
interests and their ideas and their
habits so they were they were an
extraordinary group I mean a group
unlike any other before or since not
just if for the way they for what they
did but also the way they went about it
being original the whole time for
example and and also getting out you
know I've talked about this with my
friend Jeff Martin who's here sitting
off to the side and a huge Beatle fan
like myself but very rarely never in
show business to people to part the
stage at the perfect time
and you know people sometimes more and
well the Beatles had gone on that the
Beatles had continued they it started
perfectly and it ended perfectly yes and
and that was ads I think a lot to the
beauty of it all
it ends in some pain for them yes but
there was one they were all prepared to
go through yeah I actually think one of
the people say to me what when do you
think the Beatles began to break up and
I think honestly they began to break up
the day they got together because they
were never going to do it forever yeah
because it wasn't that the personalities
within that group were the kind who
would develop other interests and to
follow them and in particular since the
Beatles were kind of formed in John
Lennon's mold he was never going to do
any one thing forever mm-hmm he was
always going to want to move on and try
something else so I think that the
Beatles came to an end at the right time
I mean at the time itself I was upset
about it I was disappointed I was you
know sorry that I wouldn't be able to
buy any more Beatle records in 1970 but
looking at it now I was kind of
hopefully more mature adults I can see
the strength of purpose that they had in
order to break up you've got the biggest
act in the world who voluntarily break
up because it isn't working for them
anymore yeah that is incredibly
courageous in their last album is Abbey
Road yeah and the last - it is the end
yeah it's if you if Hollywood wrote it
it would just be completely unbelievable
yeah um the we could talk about this for
days obviously and we'd just be
urine-soaked
at the end and dehydrated so that's not
going to happen
um I already am yeah I know trust me I I
heard and detected it some 20 minutes
ago um I keep thinking about Robert Caro
because Robert Caro Lyndon Johnson used
to be a caricature to me yes and I'm
very interested in American history and
American presidents and then Robert Caro
wrote this amazing series of
about Lyndon Johnson that turned him
from a caricature into this incredible
multifaceted and he's still going yes
and you are the Robert Caro what Robert
Caro is - Lyndon Johnson I think you are
the Beatles you have taken them on and
no one's going to do a better job than
you at this this is I mean we're all
very thankful that you've that you've
taken this on there's some concern that
how long did vol 1 take you vol 1 took
10 years ok yeah so how's your health I
mean we want I want to see this line
through I went I want to I want you to
finish this collection of books Robert
Caro said in an interview he cannot
write the portion about Vietnam with
Lyndon Johnson until he goes and lives
in a hut in North Vietnam for a year yes
I think that's extreme I want him to
finish this you know his series where
are you and in process thankfully I'm
about 30 years younger than Robert kara
good yes yeah where am i I'm researching
I'm in Los Angeles to research volumes 2
and 3 John I will go anywhere where
there's something I can learn something
that I don't already know
and I'm looking for and anyone watching
this I'm looking for any piece of paper
any document or recording or photograph
that someone watching this might think I
don't know and I'm willing obviously to
see a great deal of material that I have
seen in order for the one in a hundred
that might so anyone watching shouldn't
edit themselves don't be shy if you have
something that you a be of interest to
you something I can learn from that I
can put into this history because I
don't want to hang on to anything I'm
just doing this to put it out there yeah
because it is the most extraordinary
story the most wonderfully beautiful
story of humanity actually I find yes
that's good I want to jump in it is a
human story I want to jump in there
because I have been accused I'm in of
being because I'm such a Beatle fan and
because I and my friends and I we know
this music and we like to play and we
like to think about it and I have
and II Babiak books on the gear that
they used and I and I I have the exact
replica of John's
Epiphone you know casino that he
stripped down and plays on the rooftop
he plays it on the White Album and he
plays it on let it be down to the serial
number recreated I showed that to Elvis
Costello once thinking it was Costello
will think this is cool and also looked
at me and said that's sick looks like
but yeah there's a oh you're a nerd if
you like this much about the Beatles and
I've always thought I defend it I think
I don't I don't that doesn't sit well
with me because I think this is a story
about so much more than this amazing
rock band it is yeah there's something
that keeps pulling us back to this story
because it's about something much bigger
I can't quite explain what that is but
it to me this is about so much more than
this great rock band of the six they
have the central story of post-war
culture I would say they have the
central story and I am attempting to
tell not just their story but the entire
context of everything that was going on
around them because they didn't exist in
a vacuum they the bigger some they
plugged into everything and everyone
plugged into them so in order to tell
their story and put them in proper
context I have to tell a much broader
deeper story I told the whole story of
the music business so in the whole story
of rock and roll and all the other acts
volumes two and three will cover the 60s
from a deep cultural perspective not
just the Beatles but legitimately you
can go there with by telling the beatles
story you can spread out it takes you to
so many other players take you
everywhere you have the story of
emigration we were emigration from
Ireland to yeah
Liverpool people who probably should
have gone you know to Boston yeah it
didn't get there
yeah and stayed and stayed in Liverpool
and yeah ed Sullivan's family came on to
New York with The Beatles family stayin
in yeah in Liverpool it's a story that
you know if since they did change
everything
I have to demonstrate what things were
like before they changed them yeah the
world in which the Beatles appeared and
and the way in which everything very
rapidly revolutionizes you look at
America from 1963 the American youth say
in 1963 and American youth in 1970 as a
phenomenal change there now it isn't due
entirely to the Beatles without doubt
there's a lot of things happening but
they are the accelerants of everything
and they they show everyone that there
are other ways of doing things and
they're so positive and they're so
original in what they do but they spark
and inspire people everywhere to be
original and different and a whole
cultural revolution takes place not just
because of the Beatles but very much in
their image if you like other people are
have the opportunity to go and do
whatever they want to do so I have to
tell all that story so volumes two and
three will cover only about eight years
over the two books something like 63 to
70 but within that period of time the
whole world is changing and I have to
show that in proper detail and the
detail is the story the detail is not to
bog it down the detail is to let it sing
and this story has to sing well I'll
give you six months yeah I didn't answer
your question so I'm working on volumes
- no just finish just keep working yeah
I've taken it'll take an over an hour of
your time yeah this has been worthwhile
when this book is held up folks readers
viewers it's my fault it's your fingers
I wasted your time this was a this was a
big thrill for me
and I absolutely adore this book and and
recommend that everyone read it and like
I say it's about so much more than the
Beatles and you've done a great job
thank you good and I'll turn to my
friends quickly is there anything I've
missed that you have a question that
I've got literally got I've got fans
here of yours who are good friends of
mine so like you who and I've sold them
if you have a question you can ask a
question so do you put you on the spot
yeah I mean you're a herman's hermits
guy I know yeah more of a Jeff Martin
and I wrote on The Simpsons together and
yes and with every time we would take a
break from writing a Simpson script we
would go into one of our offices and
just talk about the teacher I think
pretty much not but unfailingly I know
and we'll do that after this that's what
we'll do after this is we will leave
this this you know our 10-minute long or
whatever it's been interview and we will
go to a restaurant around the corner and
talk about the Beatles war yeah and
you're welcome to join us
thank like I mean that is the beauty of
this subject is that it's got so many
angles of approach you can you can like
the Beatles for anyone of thousands of
different reasons yeah and they they
they they're genuine reasons as well you
don't have to go looking for them there
yeah when you when you're in a gathering
of people who like the Beatles you'll
find that everyone likes something
different yes this book is something the
same everyone who's liked it says their
favorite bit is whatever it might be and
it's never the same because they're just
such interesting people and now an LLL
end with restating what is most
remarkable about this book is it is a
thriller in a way I don't know that I
know that sounds like an odd thing to
say but your approach is the correct one
this didn't have to happen
this probably shouldn't have happened
and there are many steps along the way
when it easily couldn't have happened
yeah and the fact that it happened is is
almost like a religious experience it's
so many perfect things happen at the
right time yeah and the idea that these
four guys from a town that no one had
ever in especially the United States had
ever even heard of yeah would come
together if you had told anybody in 1959
or 1960 yeah the biggest thing in the
next decade in music is going to be for
guys from Liverpool England
you'd have been laughed if you'd said
that in England you would have been
you've been laughed out of England yeah
yeah so I wish you the best of luck keep
working
tune in Mark Lewisohn this is volume
one there's also an extended special
edition which I have at home I have both
lift it up oh there we go
it's both yes it is absolutely I mean
it's like you're writing about Winston
Churchill but it works it's beautiful
there's two volumes in there and man and
still this is just scratching the
surface so well it covers up to 62
pretty thoroughly yeah the next few
years I mean such a lot is happening
right I think we can expect something
similar very good and well thank you so
much this is gonna reel yeah it's been a
real honor thanks very much thank you
very much that's it that's our audience
we have four people clapping thank you
yeah thank you for the clap